-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
I'm doing well tonight and
I hope you're doing the same
Let's get to the news.
While preparing to board
Air Force One yesterday
on his first foreign trip
since taking office,
President Biden was hit
in the neck by a flying cicada
And get this, Biden still thinks
they can find common ground.
"Come on man,
let's work together."
President Biden addressed
group of U.S. Troops
serving abroad in the U.K.
yesterday
and promised that he wouldn'
hold back in his meeting
next week with Russian President
Vladimir Putin.
So look out, Vladimir,
you're about to get called
Buster Brown.
Before leaving yesterday for
the U.K., President Biden said
that the trip is all about
strengthening the alliance
with Europe.
That's never a good sign.
Any time a couple goes on a trip
to strengthen their alliance
you know they're about two weeks
away from a divorce.
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden me
today
with British Prime Ministe
Boris Johnson's wife, Carrie
over tea. Oh, man.
It's like those moms in the park
who only hang out
'cause their kids are friends.
"Oh, Joe -- Joe fell down.
Joe, get up, you're fine,
honey."
[ British Accent ] "Boris.
Boris, what did you just put i
your mouth?
Spit it out, Boris."
[ Normally ] After
President Biden this week
told her he would end thei
infrastructure negotiations,
Republican Senator
Shelley Moore Capito
said in an interview yesterday
that she was disappointed in
Biden's decision.
Said progressives,
"Disappointed in Biden?
Finally some common ground."
Vice President Kamala Harris
invited every female Senator
to a dinner next week at her
residence,
while Kyrsten Sinema invited
them to...adult Quidditch?
And a midnight screening o
"Rocky Horror"?
France is reportedly sending
the U.S.
a replica statue of --
a replica Statue of Liberty,
excuse me, nicknamed
"The Little Sister,"
and it'll be the only foreigne
we let in this year.
The final episode of
the reality show
"Keeping Up With the
Kardashians" aired tonight
and, if you've never seen
the show before,
trust me, you've kept up.
They're sisters
and they're rich.
Got it.
My wife loves that show.
I've never seen an episode
I only hear it while she's
watching on it her phone,
and I feel like I've heard thi
a hundred times.
[ Crying ] "It is just reall
hard having sisters."
[ Normally ] And finally, Mattel
announced today
that it will launch a new
line of Barbies
that are made from
recycled plastic
called Barbie Loves the Ocean.
Which a great idea.
I just wish they'd recycled it
a little bit more.
And that was the monologue
everybody.